hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 12 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet all I could think
about at the end of this episode was
Ward in the honey which it looked like
he was covered in honey Winnie the Pooh
and the fact that he's kind of like the
queen bee now of Hydra the reason he
keeps referring to himself as we is
because hive has a hive mind you kind of
get the idea he has those spores that he
infects people with they seem to still
have their free will but his
relationship to them is that of a queen
bee to its worker bees so queen bee
turning bees in to worker bees and they
actually did explain some of the
mechanics behind it I was actually
really happy with the script this week
very strong script they did a good job
of addressing some of the common
weaknesses I see in scripts from other
superhero TV shows and I'll talk about
it as I go along there we go top 5 WTF
and there are a bunch of Easter eggs
I'll talk about them on the way to
number 5
welcome back absorbing man this is
crusher creel from the comics we haven't
seen him since last season when he
grabbed the obelisk and he did not die
so shield is really curious about that
because anyone who doesn't have inhuman
DNA
and touch the obelisk vaporized on the
spot so why was he able to touch the
obelisk if he's not an inhuman well in
the comics there are mutants that
undergo terrigenesis like Quicksilver it
takes their powers to crazy levels but
the way they explained it on the TV show
had to do with the vaccine so number 4
WTF the adaptability of crusher creoles
DNA makes it a perfect vaccine for those
that have not undergone terrigenesis
so in the wrong hands this could be used
to inoculate people against terror
Genesis when I should mention crusher
creel Easter Egg for daredevil which is
dropping this Friday during season 1 of
daredevil Matt's father had to fight
crusher creel in the boxing ring that
was the final fight that he was supposed
to throw but he ended up winning number
3 WTF everybody is flipping sides so
they had the symposium in a lot of the
comedy was forgettable just making
Talbot wear the dress all this
ridiculous stuff but the really fun part
was the way they played with your
expectations as to what was really going
on crusher and Talbot are the informants
they're working with Malick but then you
know twist you learned that he is
secretly keeping Talbot son hostage
twist back and they're best of friends
so Talbot is back on Team Coulson they
tried to make him sympathetic this
entire episode like his wife is leaving
him he's like ah God look I gotta put up
with this and I got to put up with
Coulson in the same day then they blame
his betrayal on what Malick was doing
with his son they just want you to think
of the Talbot character as a good person
especially after last season when he and
Coulson were butting heads so much
number two WTF a lot of the world's
governments are stockpiling Inhumans the
way you would stockpile nuclear warheads
so they're teasing an inhuman Cold War
and what a coincidence that it's the
Russians that's going to be stockpiling
Inhumans for Hydra without really
knowing it maybe but it is a really nice
reference to real-world history in the
Cold War Between the Soviet Union in
America even though the Russian delegate
is friends with Malick the Russian
doesn't seem like he's Hydra or have any
idea about what Malik's plan is and
finally number one WTF this is so much
fun
hive jumps into the honey pot so it
ingests the rest of the humans that it
needs to five like the five-headed Hydra
to become whole again totally loved how
these other two Inhumans just looked at
each other like they were gonna throw up
in their mouths and then walked away but
for hive started to feed like oh Jesus
so you get the sense like Lincoln had
that speech at the end where he talked
about the war inside his head there's a
war going on outside my head I'm trying
to figure my powers out the same thing
is happening inside these two Inhumans
heads and then I think what might end up
happening later this season is that like
Lincoln will be infected with hive
spores you know have to find a way to
break that mental programming but let me
know in the comments this is actually
kind of funny when you saw hive in that
post did you one think terminator
because he was like in the Terminator
Arnold Schwarzenegger pose or - did you
think he was just rolling around in
honey
what's gonna happen next is is I have a
flash video that I'm still working on
there's some new spider-man Civil War so
be sure to subscribe to get that stuff
my first daredevil season 2 episode
video like my daredevil episode 1 video
won't post till Friday so that's still a
little ways away why you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for like the last big daredevil trailer
and you can click here for my Black
Panther Civil War video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you